there is a trailer out
to a show
that I know that they're going to make
me watch I know that daily wire is going
to force me to watch this
and that fills me with Dread
it's really hard to look back on it now
and go what on Earth happened
[Music]
[Applause]
the Royal Rockstar
and then
everything changed there's a hierarchy
of the family you know there's leaking
but there's also planting of stories
there was a war against Megan to suit
other people's agendas it's about hatred
it's about race it's a dirty game
and suffering of women marrying into
this institution this feeling frenzy
I realized they're never going to
protect you
I was terrified I didn't want a history
to repeat itself
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth
I love that it ends on that
contradiction just to show you how
stupid this whole thing is
no one knows the full truth
we know the full truth well you just
said no one knows the full truth man you
just this is not giving me confidence
and there's actually some deception in
that trailer too there's a picture of
the the paparazzi taking photographs of
of Meghan Markle it would seem that's
the implication it's not it was a photo
taken long before Meghan Markle ever
entered into the picture
it may have been a photo from a sporting
event but it was it was so even just
that
shows you how deceptive this is but no
one's buying this at all right no one's
buying that nobody knows the trouble
that Harry and Megan have seen and it's
not as though Meghan Markle had were
just drawn into the royal family
accidentally you know she met a guy at a
bar and then she finds out after she
accepts this wedding proposal oh my gosh
he's a prince no you're just my luck I
thought I met a nice accountant who
would have a private life in the suburbs
and I turns out my his name's Harry I
don't know if you know he's got red hair
turns out he's a prince can you imagine
ah just my luck
Meghan Markle who obviously went to
England to go print shopping with the
goal of marrying into this family but
why did she want to leave them
because all she wanted was the perks of
the family and she didn't realize that
the family actually serves that the
point of the monarchy is not is not what
the libs and the Communists would have
you believe which is just to drink
champagne and enjoy all this luxury the
point of the monarchy is actually to
suppress your personality suppress your
personal desires and just serve the
country you are not when you are The
Sovereign you are not really permitted
to be an individual
you were supposed to suppress all of
that that's what the crown does that's
what the vestments do that's why this is
why priests put on investments at church
on Sunday and this is this is why the
royalty do that as well it's not to make
themselves look like a rock star or
something quite the opposite it's to
cover up their personality and and to to
find themselves subsumed within the
institution as The Sovereign they don't
want to do that
this is another it actually ties in
with what we we've been talking about
about privatization
right it ties in with this idea that
neither the left nor the right want to
serve their country anymore but what
John F Kennedy said when he said ask not
what your country could do for you but
what you can do for your country that is
now a meaningless statement to both the
left and the right
because the left looks at it they say I
hate my country my country is an evil
white supremacist bigoted terrible it's
the worst place in the world I want to
burn it down and then the right says
what do I care about my country my
country is that with that government I
hate the government the common good I
don't know what the common good means
and I'm gonna certain no I'm not I'm
going to go down to Wall Street and make
a lot of money greed is good baby let's
boost up that GDP let's Outsource some
jobs let's open up the borders and let's
just lower wages and let's have ruthless
competition yeah baby and so it's that's
what you've got and you've gotten two
sides of the same coin from both the
left and the right
redounding uh to to damage to the
country the entire time and it was a
really dumb bet for the right to make
because now all that privatization we
gave up All That Power from our
political order and now it's being
wielded by people who hate our guts not
a good it was a Faustian bargain if you
ask me
do not be distracted by parties and
presents this Christmas season instead
join Hallow's most anticipated prayer
challenge of the Year pray 25. hallow is
the number one Christian Prayer app in
the U.S and the number one Catholic app
in the world hello features over 5 000
prayers and meditations including the
rosary with Bishop Baron and Mark
Wahlberg the Bible in a year with father
Mike Schmitz and Bible bedtime stories
with Jonathan Rooney hallow helps make
prayer a priority this Christmas with
pray 25 you can do the same for you led
by cast members from The Chosen the
largest Christian streaming Series in
history pray 25 will guide you through
meditation and prayer for 25 days
leading up to Christmas pray 25 will
help grow your understanding of mankind
and develop a disciplined prayer habit
during a season when discipline is put
to the test find peace and fortify your
faith this Christmas with hallow
download the app for free and join the
pray 25 challenge go to hallow.com
Michael Knowles get three months
completely free
I absolutely adore this app hello.com
Michael Knowles to reclaim your piece
during this Christmas season lawlessness
is a huge problem here okay
look at look at the Democrats they don't
feel they have to be accountable at all
Joe Biden was just asked what he is
doing about the Border
here's Biden's answer
because they're more important thing
going on they're going to invest
billions of dollars in a new Enterprise
yeah we got bigger problems
this is a major problem according to
public opinion polls if you look at
public opinion polls right now the the
issue of immigration is important to
everybody not just Republicans Democrats
too the majority of Americans want to
drastically reduce all immigration to
the United States
but Mr President you're flooding the
country with two million illegals every
single year yeah we got bigger problems
whatever moving what are you going to do
to me
what are you going
to do to me
when you're seeing this lawlessness
trickle down everywhere look right now
in North Philly
is a gas station owner who has just
hired private security
to ensure that his customers can fill up
their tanks
and when I say private security by the
way
I'm not talking about a mall cop with a
billy club I'm talking about guys who
are clad out in Black
with a very impressive black rifles
masks covering their face hoodies up
armor on
because in a major American city the
city
where we had the Continental Congress
okay the city with the Liberty Bell
people cannot fill up their gas tanks
without fear of being shot
this is a breakdown of
the political order
and you're going to see more of it
you're going to see more and more I hate
to give the Libertarians any credit here
but increasingly you are going to see
more and more the
wealthy
hiring their own security
what did you think was going to happen
the Democrats call for defunding the
police and abolishing the police for two
years well they did that in many places
and what happens you need cops you need
security and so people are going to
start hiring at themselves and this is
the acceleration of a trend that has
been really tough in the United States
and it's not only the left's fault
the the right has actually played a role
in this for the last half century you
have seen the privatization
of our country
and I know the Republicans from many
years at least talked about how great
privatization is we need to privatize
everything the government's always bad
well at a certain point then
you end up in a situation where the
people who control your political order
are basically completely unaccountable
you privatize the Public Square okay now
Facebook Google and Twitter control the
Public Square which means they control
the American political order and until
Elon Musk bought it they all hated us
and they could rig elections
if you you if you privatize your whole
country away
you're you're yes you've reduced the
risk of big government sometimes but now
you're just beholden to corporations and
if my rights and way of life are being
taken away by some awful corporation
that hates me I don't feel any better
than if the government were taking my
rights and my way of life away
Democrats privatized the social sector
Republicans privatized the economy and
now we've got private police forces
that's the best we can do because we
don't even have a police force anymore
not good
at all and you've got Joe Biden saying
oh yeah our borders that's not important
now you know it's woke Wednesday
we have a great great presentation today
to educate all of us to open up our
minds
from Love Don't Judge okay I'm gonna I
want you to have your Consciousness
elevated with me we're going to reserve
our judgment we're going to see how long
we can reserve our judgment while
watching this the rest of the show
continues now if you're not a member
click the link in the description and
join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]